Since the beginning of mankind as a species,
weapons have been some of our cleverest and most important inventions.
Over hundreds and thousands of years of war and killing,
humanity has continued to devise new ways to kill one another.
Often in brutal fashion.
From the club, to the spear
to the bow, the catapult, the musket
up till today, with those nukes we looked at in the last video.
They all serve the same purpose
but, over the course of several international conventions
some of these weapons have been banned from warfare for being too inhumane
If the sole purpose of these devices is to kill the enemy,
What makes one method more inhumane than another?
Lets say you and I are on different sides of a military conflict in the mid 1600s
We're taking shots at each other with our horribly inaccurate rifles, until finally you get a hit.
Luckily for me your bullet just grazed me.
Somewhat less luckily I die from infections a few days later
Why?
Because it the 1600s and you like to store your bullets in corpses or latrine pits
to make sure that if you do manage to hit somebody, they die from infection.
This storing of bullets in poisonous or infectious substances was the catalyst for the Strasbourg Agreement of 1675
The first ever international agreement banning the use of chemical weapons
The general sentiment was that using such an indirect and unpleasant means to kill the enemy was not befitting the principles of "civilized warfare".
Lets fast forward to the 22nd of April, 1915
The second battle of Ypres in Belgium during WW1 saw the first successful mass use of poison gas in war.
The german army released 171 tons of chlorine gas over a stretch of about 6.5 kilometers.
Chlorine gas is a really nasty substance.
It irritates the eyes and skin
and when inhaled it reacts violently with the human body causing the lungs to fill with fluid.
Those unlucky enough to be caught in the gas cloud
often drown painfully from the fluid inside their own lungs
As chlorine gas was a rather new development in weaponry
the methods the germans used to deploy it was quite crude.
The chlorine was stored in nearly 6000 cylinders
weighing 41 kilograms each.
Which the germans carried by hand to the frontlines.
The canisters was opened by hand as soon as the winds shifted towards the French
Releasing a sweeping clump of noxious gas.
The germans themselves suffered many injuries and deaths from their own gas
as it was impossible to control once out of the canisters.
When the chlorine reached the French lines
within 10 minutes 6000 had died due to aspyixiation
and tissue damage to the lungs.
Since chlorine gas is denser than air
it quickly flown down into the trenches
causing the French troops to scramble over the top to escape...
... right into german gunfire.
Chlorine gas and several other poisonous chemicals
continued to see use throughout the rest of the war.
Accounted for 1.3 million casaulties
and were the driving factor behind the well-known Geneva Protocol of 1925
It's full title was:
The Protocol for the Prohibition of the Use in War of
Asphyxiating, Poisonous or Other Gases
and of Bacteriological Methods of Warfare.
Doesn't exaltly roll off the tongue...
In essence, the Geneva Protocol is a treaty
that bans the use of chemical and biological weapons in international armed conflicts.
Like the Strassburg Aggreement.
The thinking behind the generic protocol was that chemical weapons
caused unnecessary pain and suffering in its victims
as well as significant mental and emotional trauma
several years later WWII came along
and with it a new batch of devious weapons
the Japanese employed horrible
booby traps to defend their homeland
the most famous being the hidden spike fits
soldiers would step on a thin layer of
foliage and tumble down into rows of
sharpened bamboo spikes to make matters
worse the Japanese often coded despite
his human or animal feces which led to
terrible infections among the injured
these traps killed and maimed thousands
of troops over the course of the war the
Americans had their own new toys as well
namely the two atomic bombs that
decimated Hiroshima and Nagasaki world
WWII also saw the devastating use of napalm
napalm was the ideal incendiary
weapons because it was incredibly simple
and cheap to produce it was stable and
it stuck to whatever it hit all those
features made napalm very popular and
accounted for more dead Japanese
soldiers and civilians and the two
atomic bombs
once the dust of the Second World War
settled America enjoyed relative peace
until the disastrous vietnam war with
the jungle terrain came new means of
killing what better way to clear foliage
and flush out the enemy then by using
fire a flamethrower used extensively in
both world wars proved itself
particularly useful and torching entire
villages and hideouts napalm bombs also
saw extensive use with the u.s.
reportedly dropping about 388,000 tons
of it over the course of the war
compared to 16,500 times in World
to the Vietnam War was hugely unpopular
among the American public for many reasons
among those were concerned that
these fire weapons were cruel and inhumane
sure enough on october tense 1980
the united nations convention on
certian conventional weapons came to a close and
with it came to legislation that
prohibited the use of many different
types of weapons incendiary devices are
listed under what's referred to as
protocol 3, which restricts their use in
any situation in which civilians are present
interestingly napalm isn't entirely banned it
can be used to set fire to forested
areas that conceal enemy troops or
vehicles but it's strictly prohibited
in civilian inhabited areas
other weapons ban by the CCCW include any form
of gas, including tear gas, which can still
be used in domestic riots, oddly enough,
Spike Pits, undetectable fragment weapons
meaning any weapon with the primary
effect of leaving shrapnel in human body
that is undetectable by x-ray
also included are non self-destructing
and non self-deactivating mines outside
fenced monitored and marked areas
these mines must also be removed from the
conflict is resolved and finally perhaps
more relevant to today's battlefield
blinding laser weapons, any weapon with
the ability to cause permanent blindness
or severe irreversible eye damage is
strictly prohibited.
so what do we make of all this, even
though we have a long list of prohibited weapons
what's the common thread? what exactly
makes them more inhumane than a bayonet
or a 50 caliber machine gun? As you may
have guessed the main concern is not for
the combatant but for civilian
populations the protocols are very firm
on the position that indiscriminate
weapons (weapons that cannot be used to
target only hostile troops) must never be used
that includes cluster bombs they
can blanket a wide area large explosives
like nuclear bombs and hidden weapons
such as mines and booby traps, of course
the secondary concern for the CCW was
indeed the humanity of the combatants
death at the hands of another is
certainly a tragic fate but at least
nations have been able to come together
and recognize that no one deserves to
suffer unnecessarily the future of war
is bound to be interesting with later
restrictions and technological advances
maybe we'll even see a complete ban on
human involvement in war computers and
drones of all sorts stand poised to
change the battlefield forever we'll
just have to wait and see how long it
takes that future to arrive as always
this video is intended to spark your
curiosity in the subject if you'd like
to learn more about banned or inhumane
weapons check out the links in the discription
if you enjoyed this video please
take a moment to subscribe to my channel
to help me keep posting two videos a week
feel free to leave a like or dislike as
you please and tell me what you think
about banned weapons and warfare in
general in the comments you can watch my
previous video by clicking here or binge
watch them all by clicking here
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video